[Musique]
la mort de kayes lorraine suite ma vidéo
théorie sur kai de rennes j'ai reçu
beaucoup de commentaires disant que ce
dernier était mort suite à son combat
contre ret pourquoi le serait-il la
plupart des personnes est en fait cette
remarque on déduit laborde key lorraine
car celui ci est allongé battu par reste
utah leur combat est bien évidemment car
là-bas starkiller est en train de
s'effondrer
je comprends tout à fait pourquoi
certains ont pensé ceci mais c'est faux
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
mais évidemment tout ceci se base à
cause d'une erreur de montage si on
réfléchit 5 secondes
on se rend compte que les personnes
croyant la mort de kyle aurait non pas
affirmer une énorme bêtise
remettons nous dans le contexte là bas
starkiller est en train de se détruire
tous les effectifs de snobs doivent
évacuer mais cahill lorraine voulant sa
vengeance contre ret décida de la
poursuivre jusque dans la forêt loin de
la base le combat se passe alors que la
planète est en train de se détruire
quel lorraine perdu son affrontement est
fine et allongée encore conscient face à
ret mais à ce moment précis de la
planète et au point culminant de son
implosion et c'est là que l'erreur
débarque key lorraine est allongé battus
loin de la base et surtout loin de
prendre un vaisseau on a juste une
vulgaire transition où nous voyons le
vaisseau partir avec ray chewbacca aux
commandes
cependant le combat s'est déroulé à côté
du vaisseau donc ils n'ont pas mis
longtemps pour partir mais key lorraine
voilà je vous ai expliqué en quoi ce
serait totale mais tout ceci est
totalement faux pourquoi sortons du film
cai lorraine et le personnage commercial
de 'star wars' est tout le marketing de
cette nouvelle saga se base sur lui que
ce soit des posters des masques des
peluches ou encore toutes autres goodies
même dans le trailer il est l'un des
premiers personnages à faire son
apparition
d'ailleurs tout le film tourne autour
aussi de cas et lorraine et non que de
ré on en sait encore trop peu sur lui
ses origines ses motivations je parle
par exemple de son passage du côté
obscur dont il a été par les vagues man
ou encore le simple flash back sur les
chevaliers de rennes
on n'a pas encore vu le m key lorraine
accompagné des autres chevaliers on ne
sait rien sur la rébellion de ceux ci
face à l'udc dans l'académie bref il
manque beaucoup trop d'informations pour
que kay et lorraine
ensuite je vais soulever un détail
n'oublions pas que snow qu'a ordonné à
eux deux de partir avec cai lorraine
pour finir son entraînement cela
sous-entend qu'il est encore vivant et
même kelly lorraine est l'un des
personnage principal du film
ils ne jouent pas un simple second rôle
on sent quand que kay lorraine aura une
place beaucoup plus importante et
surtout un rôle à jouer se révélera-t-il
face à snober retournera-t-il du côté
lumineux ou bien mourir at-il dans un
combat contre l'udc
on ne sait rien de tout ça seul l'avenir
nous le dira juste un seul argument pour
contrer cette idée il est le personnage
qui fait tout le marketing de star wars
est ce n'est par ray ni fini ni l'udc
s'écaille lorraine beaucoup de choses
tournent autour de ce personnage
il a un lien avec quasiment tout le
monde pour finir sur cette mini
théorique alors n est un adepte du côté
obscur il est puissant et veulent
devenir encore plus je ne pense pas que
six kilos reine devait mourir car pour
moi il ne mourra pas de par son
importance il aura un terrible combat
épique
avant de trépasser merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'aimerais avoir vos avis
sur cette théorie
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus ça m'aide énormément c'était targo
rock que le leinster soit allé
[Musique]